the biden administration is raising the
alarm level over a possible cyber attack
from russia critical american
infrastructure could be a target at
o'keefe is at the white house ed good
morning good morning nate in warning of
potential cyber attacks the president
told top american business leaders last
night they have a patriotic duty to
prepare their companies for potential
attacks and he warned that the potential
for russia to inflict more deadly
violence is likely
president biden had a stark warning
monday night the magnitude of russia's
cyber capacity is fairly consequential
and it's coming administration officials
say there's no evidence of a specific
credible threat but cyber security
experts tell cbs news they're
particularly concerned about potential
attacks on the u.s financial sector
power grid and water systems as a
precaution federal officials in recent
days gave classified briefings to some
companies tied to infrastructure there
is some preparatory activity that we're
seeing and that is what we shared in a
classified context so preparatory
activity could mean
scanning websites it could be hunting
for vulnerabilities in his speech to top
business leaders the president also said
russia is falsely claiming the u.s and
ukraine are using chemical or biological
weapons in ukraine that's a clear sign
he's considering using both of those and
we should be careful about what's about
to come he knows there'll be severe
consequences because of the united nato
front and though the pentagon couldn't
verify russia's claim of using a
powerful new weapon mr biden said it's a
threat that's almost impossible to stop
they've just
launched a highly hypersonic missile
because it's the only thing that they
can get through with an absolute
certainty
meantime the pentagon now confirms it is
helping collect evidence of war crimes
in russia and later this morning the u.n
general assembly will hold a rare
session to discuss what to do about the
ongoing humanitarian crisis in ukraine
gail
all right ed thank you very much